your fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with this man's name that is
impossible to pronounce
my name is dr. Khurana if I hear and
indeed it seems that pronouncing my name
requires some advanced technology so
what was this I promise to tell you in a
moment but to understand what happened
here first let's have a look at this
deep fake technique we showcased a few
videos ago as you see we are at a point
where our mouth head and eye movements
are also realistically translated to a
chosen target subject and perhaps the
most remarkable part of this work was
that we don't even need a video of this
target person just one photograph
however these deep fake techniques
mainly help us in transferring video
content so what about voice synthesis is
it also as advanced as this technique we
are looking at well let's have a look at
an example and you can decide for
yourself this is a recent work that goes
by the name techo Tron 2 and it performs
aei based voice cloning all this
technique requires is a 5 second sound
sample of us and is able to synthesize
new sentences in our voice as if we
utter these words ourselves let's listen
to a couple examples the Norseman
considered the rainbow is a bridge over
which the gods passed from Earth to
their home in the sky take a look at
these pages 4 Crooked Creek Drive
there are several listings for gas
station
here's the forecast for the next four
days
Wow these are truly incredible the
timbre of the voice is very similar and
it is able to synthesize sounds and
consonants that have to be inferred
because they were not heard in the
original voice sample and now let's jump
to the next level and use a new
technique that takes a sound sample and
animates the video footage as if the
target subject said it themselves this
technique is called neural voice
puppetry and even though the voices here
are synthesized by this previous taiko
Tron 2 method that you heard a moment
ago we shouldn't judge this technique by
its audio quality but how well the video
follows these given sounds let's go the
president of the United States is the
head of state and head of government of
the United States indirectly elected to
a four-year term by the people through
the Electoral College the office holder
leads the executive branch of the
federal government and is the
commander-in-chief of the United States
Armed Forces there are currently 4
living former presidents
if you decide to stay until the end of
this video there will be another fun
video sample waiting for you there now
note that this is not the first
technique to achieve results like this
so I can't wait to look under the hood
and see what's new here after processing
the incoming audio the gestures are
applied to an intermediate 3d model
which is specific to each person since
each speaker has their own way of
expressing themselves you can see this
intermediate 3d model here but we are
not done yet we feed it through a neural
renderer and what this does is apply
this motion to the particular face model
shown in the video you can imagine the
intermediate 3d model as a crude mask
that models the gesture as well but does
not look like the face of any one where
the neural render adapts the mask to our
target subject this includes adapting it
to the current resolution lighting face
position and more all of which is
specific to what is seen in the video
what is even cooler is that this new
rendering part runs in real-time so what
do we get from all this well one
superior quality but at the same time it
also generalizes to multiple targets
have a look here you know I think we're
in a moment of history we're probably
the most important thing we need to do
is to bring the country together and one
of the skills that I bring to bear and
the list of great news is not over yet
you can try it yourself the link is
available in the video description make
sure to leave a comment with your
results to sum up by combining multiple
existing techniques it is important that
everyone knows about the fact that we
can both perform joint video and audio
synthesis for a target subject this
episode has been supported by weights
and biases here they show you how to use
their tool to perform phase swapping and
improve your model that performs it also
weights and biases provides tools to
track your experiments in your deep
learning projects their system is
designed to save you a ton of time and
money and it is
actively used in projects at prestigious
labs such as open AI Toyota research
github and more and the best part is
that if you are an academic or have an
open-source project you can use their
tools for free it really is as good as
it gets
make sure to visit them through w and be
calm slash papers or just click the link
in the video description and you can get
a free demo today
our thanks to weights and biases for
their long-standing support and for
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I will see you next
time